Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Neural style transfer just appeared four years
ago, in 2015.
Style transfer is an interesting problem in
machine learning research where we have two
input images, one for content, and one for
style, and the output is our content image
reimagined with this new style.
The cool part is that the content can be a
photo straight from our camera, and the style
can be a painting, which leads to the super
fun results that you see here.
However, most of these works are about photos.
So what about video?
Well, hold on to your papers because this
new work does this for video and the results
are marvelous.
The process goes as follows: we take a few
keyframes from the video, and the algorithm
propagates our style to the remaining frames
of the video, and, WOW, these are some silky
smooth results.
In specific, what I would like you to take
a look look at is the temporal coherence of
the results.
Proper temporal coherence means that the individual
images within this video are not made independently
from each other, which would introduce a disturbing
flickering effect.
I see none of that here, which makes me very,
very happy!
And now, hold on to your papers again because
this technique does not use any kind of AI.
No neural networks and other learning algorithms
were used here.
Okay, great, no AI.
But, is it any better than its AI-based competitors?
Well, look at this!
Hell yeah!
This method does this magic through building
a set of guide images, for instance, a mask
guide highlights the stylized objects, and
sure enough, we also have a temporal guide
that penalizes the algorithm for making too
much of a change from one frame to the next
one, ensuring that the results will be smooth.
Make sure to have a look at the paper for
a more exhaustive description of these guides.
Now if we make a carefully crafted mixture
from these guide images and plug them in to
a previous algorithm by the name StyLit, we
talked about this algorithm before in the
series, the link is in the video description,
then, we get these results that made me fall
out of my chair.
I hope you will be more prepared and held
on to your papers.
Let me know in the comments!
And you know what is even better?
You can try this yourself because the authors
made a standalone tool available free of charge,
just go to ebsynth.com, or just click the
link in the video description.
Let the experiments begin!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!